Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most respected fields today
and earning your CIS certification can
open the door to some of the highest
paying and most trusted roles in the
industry. But passing the CIS isn't just
about memorizing facts. It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly what
this course is designed to do. I will
walk you through every domain, simplify
complex topics and share real world
example that will help you not only pass
the exam but truly master cyber
security. So before we begin, like this
video, hit that subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell.
Hi everyone and welcome to our CIS
course. In today video we will go
through domain three security
architecture and engineering. This
domain carries a weightage of 13% in
overall CIS exam content. So let's get
started.
Topics overview. So these are the topics
that we will go through in this videos.
Secure design principles concepts of
security model such as biba model bell
laadulla model and other security
models. How to assess and mitigate
vulnerabilities of security architecture
design and solutions. Then we'll come to
our important topic the cryptographic
solutions.
Then the crypt analytic attacks are
different attacks on cryptographic
solutions. And
uh last we will study the site and
facility security controls. We can also
see these are the physical controls that
are required physical as well as logical
control required for security of your
physical facility as well as the site.
Our first topic is secure system
development. So the stages of a secure
system development include design. These
are generic stages. They may vary as per
the requirement or as per the framework
but generally they are initial stage is
the design of the system and we develop
the system. Before implementation, we
test the system. Then we finally
implement the system and then we go
through the maintenance uh stage uh of
the system which is ongoing ongoing
maintenance maintenance of the system
and when we finally the system run out
of its uh life you can say its useful
life it is the commission.
So the key point or important point to
remember and consider here is that
integrate security early in the design
phase. This is very important and expect
one or few questions
at your exam that the early you
integrate security in your design or
your system development the better it
is. So if you usually security is
integrated traditionally after the
system is implemented
but the more secure and better approach
is to integrate security
earliest and the earliest phase here is
the design phase. So we need to start
integrating security here in this design
phase. Why? So these are the reason for
integrating security early in the design
because earlier integration security is
cheaper and easier to build security
during design rather retrofit it later.
It ensures both user and systems
component comply with security
requirements protecting confidentiality
integrity and availability.
So now coming over to some secure design
principle according to ISO
and these include the first principle is
the principle of least privilege which
means granting only minimum access
needed for task and only for as long as
required.
List privilege limits potential damage
from error and attacks. What does this
mean? This means that let's suppose a
user is doing something on a system and
he or she you can say
by mistake deletes something. So if
the user was using let's suppose the
admin account or you can say the root
account
which is which has high privileges the
damage will be very high if something uh
unwanted is done through this account.
On the other hand, if the user was using
a simple account with limited
privileges, for example, let's suppose
we can say a guest account. Even if
something mistakenly is done, the damage
will be limited. So that's why it is
important that we always use non-admin
and nonroot account for daily operation,
daily task or routine task. For example,
in Linux, the pseudo command temporarily
grants admin rights. For example, we
want to do something that requires admin
credential. We just temporarily use the
pseudo command and the task is performed
using the admin rights and then the user
rewards back to the user accounts to
perform other tasks.
Next design principle is attack surface
minimization. Important one. This uh
concept or this principle reduces all
potential entry points for attacks. It
minimizes the attack surface and this is
achieved by removing unneeded services
ports or component and simplifying the
workflow. For example, system hardening
and disabling unused network ports.
System hardening means let's suppose you
have a Windows laptop. So you can harden
this laptop by disabling unused
services, unused ports, enabling the
firewall, installing the antivirus
solution etc.
So next the secure design principle is
the centralized parameter validation and
what does this mean? This mean that we
need to use a single shared library to
validate all user and system inputs. For
example, we have a system. The system
may be let's suppose a database.
We are having request from multiple side
from multiple users. So it is important
that we have a centralized system to
validate all these input request. So
this prevents invalid or malicious data
from entering the system. An example
includes secure coding input validation
or web application firewall.
For example, if I give the example of
the web application web firewall, it
means that all the request must go
through this firewall
and this firewall basically validates
the input for security and then passes
it onward to the you can say the
application and then
eventually to the database. So the
centralized parameter validation is an
important security rather than uh
deploying decentralized security
solution for each input or for
each user. The centralized input
validation or parameter validation is
uh a secure design principle.
The fourth security design principle is
centralized general security services.
This means managing core security
functions such as authentication,
logging and key management centrally.
Again, keep in mind that centralized
security implementation is good, simpler
and you can also say cheap than doing
this uh security implementation
decentralized. So be uh the why it is so
because it simplifies management. It
reduces errors and improves consistency.
An example is centralized access control
system or seam system. So the seam is a
security information and event
management. It is a type of
solution where the
logs from all types from all the systems
are centralized over here
you can say that the logs from network
devices logs from database logs from
let's suppose edge devices let's suppose
edr
logs from clients logs from server all
these are
centralized at the same solution and uh
it is fair that the logs are correlated
and
make use of
and number five is
prepare for error and exception
handling. So systems must detect, handle
and log errors without leaking sensitive
detail. So when there is some error
inside the system, we can see an error
message. So the error message should be
such that it does not reveal any
sensitive information about the system.
For example, its IP addresses, username
and passwords, etc.
The system should be designed to fail
safe and stay secure during error or
failure. For example, if a system is
about to fail and it fails, it should
fail safe without revealing any
sensitive information.
Example,
sorry. Example, ATMs reject overdraft
attempts and display safe error
messages. What does this mean? This
means that if you try to withdraw an
amount from the ATM which is more than
you have in your account, the ATM ATM
would just display a message that uh
let's suppose for example insufficient
balance in your account rather than
displaying other unnecessary information
that could reveal inside information of
the account or of the bank database etc.
So our next topic and an important topic
uh to consider is the threat modeling.
So the threat modeling purpose is to
identify, analyze and prioritize
potential security threats and
vulnerabilities during system design or
operation to reduce risk.
So in this topic we will go through
common threat modeling framework and
these are very important. The threat
modeling frameworks include stride, red
and fast. So we will go through all
these one by one. What does we mean by
them? How they are used. So these are
important. You should uh remember
abbreviation of these threat model as
well as uh how they are used what does
mean. So let's go and let's start with
the first one that is stride.
So stride is developed by the Microsoft
and this threat model tries to help
answer that what can go wrong by
classifying six main threat types. You
can see we have six alphabets in this uh
model this model name and each alphabet
basically points to a specific threat
and these threats are so the S stands
for spoofing, T is tampering, R is
repudiation, I is information closure, D
is denial of service and E is elevation
of privileges. So this model basically
gives us
six thread types that what can go wrong
with your system by classifying or uh
picking or analyzing these six threads.
So the first one is spoofing. Spoofing
means impersonating another user or
system.
So what are some mitigation against
spoofing is first one is strong
password. So someone if your password is
weak someone may steal your password and
then log into the system pretending to
be you. So a mitigation technique
again password guessing or password
steering is to use strong password even
more secure than strong password is MFA
password along with another factor such
as biometric fingerprint sensor etc and
digital signature. So digital signature
also gives us authenticity origin of the
user.
Next is the T inst which stands for
tempering and temping is the
unauthorized modification of data. And
if you remember from our initial slides
in domain one temping is when in
integrity of information is compromised.
So
this thread basically compromises the
integrity of data and mitigation
techniques includes access controls,
loggings and integrity checks.
Next is the repudiation which is denying
performing an action without proof.
And again the mitigation techniques
against repudiation is secure logging
and digital signature. As I said that
digital signature is used to
uh for authenticity of some a digital
signature belong to a unique user or to
a unique system. So
if a an action is performed and a
digital signature is used the the user
or the system that perform that action
later cannot deny having performed that
action. So this uh secure logging
similarly through logs we can determine
the time stamp the user the action that
the system user perform. So this also
gives us
uh mitigation against repudiation.
Next is the I which is information
disclosure. So this one is threat
against confidentiality.
It is leaking sensitive data to
unauthorized users and protection
against information disclosure or
confidentiality is to use encryption DLP
data loss prevention and access control.
Next is the D which is denial of service
and this one is uh threat against
availability. So this one is C. No, this
this one is I
this one is B and this one is our A
which is
C I A prior and as we studied initially
this was the initial these are the some
base pillars but we need other uh
security controls to protect our
information as well besides CIA. And the
last one is so the denial of service is
making system unavailable to legitimate
users and and we studied in our CIA
triad protection against DOSS or denial
of service is redundancy filtering
unwanted traffic and rate limiting. So
the in denial of service attack the
attacker basically flood the system with
attacks. If you rate limit the traffic
the flood of flood of traffic or the
cross attack won't work.
And last is the E instead which is
elevation of privileges which gaining
higher privileges than authorized and
mitigation techniques against this
threat are access control and input
validation.
So next the threat model is dread which
is a quantitative threat rating. So we
will see how it is quantitative as we
study that the quantitative basically
deals with digits or numbers and the
purpose of this model is to assess and
prioritize security threats based on
their potential impact and
exploitability.
So basically in this as we said that it
is a quantitative threat modeling.
We give score from 1 to 10 to each of
these you can say uh
categories
uh the each of these threads
and then we aggregate them and we get
number. So the you can say the threat
that has the highest number then gets
the higher priority for
mitigation.
So for an example there is a threat and
then we for that particular threat we
get score for each of these. So in red D
is for damage that how much harm can
this threat cause.
So if let's suppose our rating is from 1
to 10. So if it causes a harm of one or
two it means it is less damaging or and
if the threat causes a harm of let's
suppose 8 9 10 it very high damaging.
What it measures? It measures business
or operational fact that how damaging it
is for the business or business
operations. Next is the reproducibility
which means how easily can the attack be
repeated
and it measures the consistency and ease
of replicating the attack. Next is the
exploitability which means how much
effort is needed to exploit
the vulnerability in the system and it
measures the skill time or tool required
to carry out the or exploit the
vulnerability.
A in red is for affected user. So how
many users are impacted or affected by
that particular threat. So it gives the
scope and reach of the thread. the more
the user the more uh damaging that uh
threat is or the more score that threat
will particular category of that threat
with. Last one is discoverability which
mean how easily can the vulnerability be
found inside the system. So it is the
likelihood of discovery by attackers. So
if it is easy to be found it means it
will get a higher score and if it is
very difficult to be discovered it mean
will get a lower score. So in this way
we let's suppose we have five threats
uh posed to an organization
and we
assess each threat through this model
and each one of these get different
number. For example, threat number one
get
25 marks or 25 score. Next one get
40. Next one get 29. This one get let's
suppose 90 and last one get 23. So how
we then uh use the score for we use the
score for
mitigation. So the 41 the threat having
the 40 score will be mitigated first
followed by the threat having 29 score
then 25 23 and 19.
So our next threat model is the PASTA
which stands for process for attack
simulation and threat analysis and its
purpose is that it is a sevenst step
riskbased threat modeling framework
which was developed in 2012 that aligns
business objectives with technical risk
and uses an attack centric view to build
effective mitigation strategies.
So this is these are the uh seven steps
inside pasta. Number one is define
objective. Number two define technical
scope. Three application decomposition.
Four threat analysis. Five vulnerability
analysis. Six is attack modeling. And
seven is risk and impact analysis.
So now let's describe and goal of each
stage one by one. So first one is define
objective which means identify key
business goals
compliance needs and conduct a prelim
uh prelim preliminary
business impact analysis or BIA
and the goal or the output of this stage
is to understand what needs protection
and why. As we studied in our first
domain,
BIA is basically input to other steps.
So for example, if you are trying to
carry out a business continuity plan,
disaster recovery plan, first you carry
out the BIA which gives you the critical
business processes that need to be
protected first.
Next is define technical scope which is
documenting all assets system
dependencies and data flows within
scope. So this gives us the uh full
visibility of the environment that what
is the technical core what are the
system what are the assets that needs
and say protection and it gives you the
overall visibility of the environment.
Number three is application
decomposition which is breaking down the
application mapping the data flow and
trust boundaries and defining the entry
points and the goal and or the output of
this stage is to understand how and
where data moves and who accesses it.
Number four is threat analysis which is
gathering threat intelligence and
identify potential attack scenarios
relevant to the system and the output or
goal of this stage is to build a list of
likely attack vectors. Number five is
vulnerability analysis which is to
identify and map vulnerabilities in
codes, systems and networks to
corresponding threats. And the goal or
output of this stage is to correlate
vulnerabilities with possible exploits.
Number six is attack modeling which is
to stimulate simulate how attacks could
exploit identified vulnerabilities.
And the output is to evaluate likelihood
and impact of each attack. And saw seven
and last stage is risk and impact
analysis
which is to refine risk priorities and
develop mitigation strategies for
residual risk. And this uh stage create
creates an actionable risk mediation
plan.
So next topic is zero trust architecture
or ZDA an important topic. So this is ZT
zero trust architect is defined by N
publication 800-207
in 2020
and this term was originally coined by
John Kender
in forest research 2010.
So what is ZTA or zero trust
architecture?
The zero trust means to never trust and
always verify. Traditionally
the slogan was to trust but
verify
but but in zero trust we say to never
trust and always verify.
No automatic trust for internal or
external users. So traditionally our
internal users were trusted users but in
ZTA
there is no one to be trusted
including internal as well as external
user. Every access request must be
authenticated, authorized and encrypted.
So traditionally the initial request was
authenticated, authorized or encrypted
but later on it was not. So but in ZTA
every request must be authenticated
otherwise and script in each client. So
it is designed to limit lateral movement
and reduced blast radius of breaches. So
these are important concept. What does
this mean?
This means that if let's suppose one of
your system is compromised. Let's
suppose this is your an application
server
and then you have other server other
application server you have database
server. So the letter moment is that if
your one server is compromised
then this attack or this uh compromise
of application should not spread to
other server. So this ZTI basically
reduces this you can say blast radius by
limiting the attack to the only one
machine on one server only and uh
limiting the lateral movement of this
attack.
So these are the core principle of ZTA.
Number one is to always verify,
authenticate and authorize every request
based on identity, location, device,
health, behavior and data sensitivity.
So it is not that you should
authenticate only the username and
password. You can use multiple criteria
such as location, health, behavior and
sensitivity to authenticate the request.
Use least use least privilege access
mean meaning granting minimum necessary
rights preferably on a just in time
basis.
What does this mean? This mean that
giving the rights only for that specific
period of time for which it is needed
and then reverting the rights back.
Assume breach means operate if
compromise has already occurred which is
designed to contain impact.
The key practices in ZTA or zero trust
architecture is to enforce MFA or
multiffactor authentication verify
device compliance before granting
access. Equip all internal communication
use micro segmentation to isolate
network zones and prevent lateral
movement. So what does micro
segmentation mean? So traditionally we
have the let's suppose this is external
boundary which we usually call untrust
and in internally we have the internal
or the
trust boundary. So all the system inside
this trust boundary they were trusted
and we have only two zone one this
external zone and internal zone. In
micro segmentation,
we further segment even our trusted or
internal systems. For example, this
system, this system and this system,
these all are micro segmented. And again
this is for the purpose that as we
studied in the previous slide if one
system is compromised
the attack or the malicious software you
can say won't spread to other system and
such
and and in such way the radius the blast
of the radius would be reduced.
So protect data based on classification
and tagging rather than location. employ
real time monitoring and analysis to
detect anomalies and inform access
decisions.
Our next topic is cloud shared
responsibility model which is a cloud
security framework that divides security
duties between the cloud service
provider CSP and the customer.
So this one uh is also important. So in
cloud we have different models such as
infrastructure as a service, software as
a service and platform as a service and
in each model the cloud service provider
and customer have different
responsibilities.
For example, in IASR infrastructure as a
service, the cloud service provider is
pro responsible for the physical host,
the hardware, the network hardware such
as switches, firewalls and the
hypervisor. So hypervisor is the
virtualization software that is
installed on the physical host while the
customer is responsible for the
operating system
application and data. So in the AAS
customer has the
has more responsibility than all the
other modules in platform as a service.
Again CSV is responsible for all these
these constitute the infrastructure as
well as the runtime while the uh
customer is responsible for data user
access and application code. So in past
customer is not responsible for
operating system rather than CSP is
response for operating system.
Infrastructure covers the OS physical
host network or provider all these
stuff. Software is a service. In this
ESP is responsible for all the above
things including infrastructure,
hypervisor, host, network as well as the
entire application and infrastructure
covers all these things while the
customer is only responsible for the
accessing the application and the data
handling inside the application.
Our
next concept is the defense in depth or
layered security which is a security
strategies that strategy that uses
multiple distinct layers of control to
prevent to protect system ensuring that
if one layer fails other
provide protection. So these are used
interchangeably. Sometime they are
called layer defense, sometime it is
defense in depth and the term of first
used by NSA.
So we have already studied in I think in
our first domain or in the second domain
where we saw that let's suppose if we
have our asset
here then we have multiple
layers of security controls
against this layer. So here we have some
controls
here. So if one layer fails
the next layers of control protect the
system. If the next fails the next
layers protect it. So this protection
mechanism is known as layer defense or
defense in depth.
And the key principles let me clear the
screen. So the key principles of layer
defense or defense in dep is that we
have multiple layers which combine
technical, administrative and physical
controls. We have redundancy which is
overlapping controls to prevent single
point of failure.
Assume bridge. So we design security
with expectation that one layer may be
compromised. Detection and response
which is prevention alone is not enough.
focus equally on monitoring and
reaction.
So now coming over to security models
which is an important topic and our
first security model is the Bell
Laadulla model or BLP model. So it is a
confidentiality focused security model
that prevents unauthorized access to
classified information and it was
developed by David Bell and Bernard
Lepadulla
that why this model is known as Bell
Lepadola. So remember the point that it
is focused on confidentiality of the
information.
So how does this work? So these are the
core principle or properties of or rules
of this model which first one is the
assess property or simple security
property
also known as no read. What does this
mean? This that a subject cannot read
data at a higher classification level.
For example, a secret a user that has
secret classification cannot read top
secret files.
So in this way this model protects
confidentiality
because the top secret confidential data
can only be viewed by top secret
clearance user. If a user has lower
plans such as secret or confidential, it
cannot read or access the top secret
files. Next is the star property which
is no write down. No read up, no write
down. So a subject cannot write to a
lower classification level. What does
this mean? This mean that let's suppose
a secret user which is a higher
classification than a confidential
classification cannot write to a
confidential file or similarly you can
say that a top secret user
cannot write
to
accurate
level files because top circuit has
higher classification. Writing data to a
lower classification would disclose that
information to users having lower
classification.
Last one optional rule is the
discretionary security property which
access is also controlled by an access
matrix defining specific subject object
permission.
So for example, department A officer can
read secret files only within their own
department. For example, if A is a user
is in department A and he has the
security clearance of secret,
it does not mean that this user can view
file in department B that has same
secret player. This is also known as
compartment
uh comp uh term for this is used uh
compartments or compartmental
uh compartment
I don't uh cannot pronounce the word
right now but there are compartment even
within the same organization
and they have their own separate files
so one user from one department cannot
access secret files from another even if
the user has the secret lens.
So this is the visual representation of
the uh bell labadulla model. So this is
no read up. What does this mean? This
means that the secret or confidential
clearance user cannot read data from the
top secret and similarly no right down
means that the top secret or secret
cannot write data to the lower
classification level that is
confidential. So this is simple security
property. This is star security
property.
Our next are so these are some of the
limitation of the bell laadulla model
and the first one is that this model
only focuses on confidentiality not
integrity and it does not address code
channel that is indirect data leakage
through timing or resource use. So these
are some of the method to which data can
be extracted from systems. one is time
and technique and the other is resource
use. So this bodulla model is better
suited for military or government
environments than commercial system. So
this is mainly used inside military as
we already studied that the secret top
secret confidential these classification
or government or military
classification.
Our next patent model is the BBA
integrity model. As the name indicates
this one covers integrity. Bella badulla
was for confidentiality. Ba is integrity
model and the purpose is it ensures data
integrity prevents unauthorized or
untrustworthy
modification.
And the key rules of this model are
first one is symbol integrity property
which is no read down. So subject cannot
read data from a lower integrity level.
So this prevent trusted processes from
using unverified data. What does this
mean? This mean that if we have a top
secret
user, it cannot read
from let's suppose secret
because that data is of less accuracy.
You can say it is of less sensitivity
and if the top secret user reads that
data the integrity of the top secret
data may be compromised because input is
taken from less verified data. High
integrity property is no right up. So
subjects cannot write data to higher
integrity level prevents less trusted
user from corrupting critical data.
Similarly so the secret cannot write
up
means secret user cannot write data to
the top secret files.
Again this is the visual representation.
So simple integrity property is that the
higher classification cannot read from
the lower classification which is no
read down and similarly lower
classification level cannot ride to the
higher classification level which is no
ride up and this property is star
integrity property.
So an example of viv by integrity model
is in a hospital system doctor's
diagnostic software operates at a higher
integrity level while patient feedback
forms are considered low integrity data.
So according to ba integrity model the
diagnostic system cannot read patient
feedback data that is no read down to
avoid basing medical decision on
unverified information. Similarly, a
patient cannot write directly to the
medical database nor right up to prevent
tempering with official medical records.
Our next model is Clark Wilson model and
this model is also integrity focused.
So it is designed to ensure data
integrity in commercial system. So the
previous two models biba and bell
ledulla they were mainly military
focused. Log Winston model was designed
keeping in mind the requirement for
commercial system. So it is based on two
main principle. First one is the
well-formed transaction which means that
only authorized validated processes can
modify data. As we said it is integrity
based. Only authorized and validated
processes can modify data to preserve
the integrity of data. And number two is
separation of duties. So no single user
can both authorize and execute a
transaction. So we studied the
separation of duties multiple time that
it is used to ensure prevention of fraud
and in extreme sensitive processes. The
process is devised among multiple user
so that a single person cannot
both such as in this case authorize as
well as execute that sensitive function.
So in order for that uh sensitive
process to be executed uh it will take
multiple parties or multiple user to uh
to collude or to conspire in order to do
fraud.
So the key components in this models are
CDI that is constrained data item which
is data whose integrity must be
maintained. Then is UDI which is
unconstrained data item which is input
data not yet validated. IVP that is
integrity verification procedure which
ensures that CDIS that is constrain data
items remain valid and TP that is
transformation procedure which is
authorized process that modifi mod
modifies the constraint data items
according to rules.
So an example in a bank system a clerk
enters a transaction which is
unconstrained data items. So it is the
input data that is not yet validated by
clerk. Then a TP
that is a transformation procedure
basically validates it and post it to
the ledger. So ledger here is the
constraint data item which is the data
whose integrity must be maintained and
an auditor that is IVP integrity
verification procedure later verifies
the accuracy.
So our next model is breer n model also
known as ethical wall or sometimes
Chinese wall. So the purpose of this
model is that it prevents conflicts of
interest by restrict restricting access
based on realer data access decisions.
What does this mean? We will know in a
while. So the key concept behind this
model is
that access decisions are dynamic. They
change depending on what information a
user has already
accessed.
The core components of this model
include
number one is the object which is
individual piece of data related to one
company. Then we have the company data
set which is the all data or objects for
a single company. And the third
component is conflict of interest or CY
class which is all company data sets
within the same industry or competing
sector.
So let's go through an example of this
rule. So for example, if an analyst
accesses Acme Finance, it is a fictional
company. So if an analyst accesses AC
acme finance data, they cannot access
AEX finance data because now it belongs
to the same class of interest
class but may access beta chemicals data
which is different class of interest. So
since finance and finance belongs to
same COI analyst cannot access both due
to conflict of interest. But if analyst
accesses finance data for from either
ACME or AEX
the analyst can then access the beta
chemicals
data due to different class of interest.
So this is how this works
diagrammatically.
So we have let's suppose Acme Finance
and AEX finance. So if analyst let's
suppose accesses acme finance
and these two are basically uh belongs
to the same conflict of interest class.
So this is the wall that we are talking
about the ethical wall. If analyst
accesses that suppose acme there is this
ethical binary that the analyst should
not now access the AEX finance because
this data can then be used for the
benefit of either organization or
insiding insider trading etc.
Our next topic is memory protection
inside information system security
capability. So information system has
security capabilities and one of them is
the memory protection. So the purpose of
memory protection is that it prevents
one process from accessing another's
process memory ensuring system stability
and confidentiality.
So this is how the memory protection
works. So the operating system assigns
specific memory areas to each process.
The memory protection unit or MPU
enforces these boundaries and if a
process tries to access unauthorized
memory, the operating system blocks or
terminates it.
What is the dual mode memory operation?
So the privilege mode or also known as
the control mode. It is controlled by uh
so the OS controls memory protection and
executes critical instructions. The next
is the user mode which is applications
where applications run with restricted
access to memory and CPU instructions.
Additional security feature is ASLR
important feature which is address space
layout randomization
which means it randomizes memory address
location to prevent attackers from
predicting where code or data resides
reducing the buffer overflow risk.
Potential weakness inside memory
protection uh in information system may
be faulty hardware or operating system
design can break the uh processes memory
isolation. The vulnerabilities like
spectre and meltdown that were
discovered in 2018 exploited CPU design
flaws to infer protected memory
contents.
Next is the secure crypto processor. So
the purpose of secure crypto processor
uh uh is
to
to do certain cryptographic operations
securely. So what is a crypto secure
crypto processor? A secure crypto
processor is a specialized hardware
module designed to perform cryptographic
cryptographic operation securely
and protect sensitive data such as keys.
So these are the core function of crypto
processor to generate two random
numbers. Secure key generation and
storage such as private and public key
encryption and digital signing using
internal keys also known as the private
keys and hardware acceleration of
cryptographic
algorithms.
These are security features of the
secure crypto processor. It is uh number
one feature is temper detection and
response. So it erases sensitive data if
tempering is detected. So if someone
want to physically temper with the
crypto processor, it has a built-in
feature to erase the sensitive data or
the keys. Physical shielding. So it
prevents probing and signal is dropping
trusted boot process. So it validates
firmware and operating system integrity
limited interface. So it reduces attack
surface for improved verification.
Now some types of crypto processor. So
the propriety crypto processor includes
the Apple secure enclave. Open standard
is TPM defined in ISO189.
So these are uh maybe standalone devices
or smart cards.
Now coming over to important topic
trusted platform module as we studied it
is a type of secure crypto processor. So
a TPM is a hardwarebased secure crypto
processor built into a systems
motherboard that provides trusted
computing functions as defined by ISO18
and the core functions of TPM TPM
includes attestation which is
verification of system integrity by
hashing non good hardware and software
states. Binding is encrypting data using
keys tied to that specific system.
And another feature or function is the
sealing which allows decryption only if
the system re remains in a verified and
trusted states. So these are some of the
feature or some of areas that reside
inside this TPM chip such as the one you
can say hash generator, RSA key
generator,
storage root key, storage keys,
encryption decryption, signature engine
etc.
Security services of TPM include that it
generates cryptographic key pair,
private key never leaves the TPM. So it
generate let's suppose public and
private key but the private key never
leaves the TPM for obvious security
reasons. It perform digital signing and
encryption decryption securely within
the chip and validates platform
integrity to detect bias or firmware
tempering.
So what are some potential weaknesses of
the TPM? First one is the manufacturer
dependency. So the endorsement key
security depends on the vendor
trustworthy worthiness. So this is the
key that is generated by the vendor and
then stored inside the TPM. So if the
vendor is trustworthy, it means the TPM
security is ensured. On the other hand,
if the uh you cannot trust the vendor,
then the whole security is compromised
or you can say that the TPM security is
then of no use because the root of trust
is
uh not trustworthy. Next is the software
defect. So we have we may have the
software defects where the TPM is used.
For example, if the TPM is used in
Windows uh based laptop and there is
some defect in the window again the TPM
security can be compromised. An example
is uh of 20 2017
uh infin uh Infinion law exposed private
keys showing supply chain leak. So user
were able to extract private keys from
the TPM
uh in 2017.
thus uh compromising the security of the
DPM. So the lesson is to always vet the
hardware vendor and maintain supply
chain risk management.
Our
next topic is HSM that is hardware
security module and definition is that
the HSM is a dedicated device that
securely generates, stores and manages
cryptographic keys and performs
encryption decryption operation and its
purpose is to provide strong physical
and logical protection for cryptographic
material reducing exposure to theft or
tempering.
So what is the difference then between
the HSM and TPM? So HSM as we said it is
a chip that is part of a system. For
example, it may be part of a server of a
PC or a laptop. On the other hand, HSM
is a dedicated hardware on its own and
its core purpose is to manage the
cryptographic keys and cryptographic
operations
and its common use is uh it is used by
CSR certification authorities to protect
their root private keys also by payment
processor for secure symmetric keys uh
of the card holder data. data and in
enterprises it is used to manage
encryption or VPNs, archives and
internal records. So as you can see the
main purpose of this is to uh you can
say manage and store the encryption
keys.
The key features include it is temper
resistant and certified. For example, it
is certified FIPS 140-2/3.
It it offers secure uh application
programmable interfaces for
cryptographic services and it operates
as a standalone appliance
uh and can be connected via network or
USB connected. So as I said it is
standalone as opposed to the TPM which
is uh part of a broader system. Our next
topic is assessing and mitigating
vulnerabilities of secure architecture
or secure system.
So the assessment methods include
inspection.
It may be manual which is reviewing the
design or configuration or automated
through tools. And the testing types
include white box which is when you have
the full system knowledge. This type of
test for example when done by the
internal employees. Black box is when
there is no internal knowledge of the
system. For example when you hire a
third party to test your system which
has no prior knowledge of your system
internal working and gray box
with it is between these two which is uh
when the user is having partial
knowledge. For example, a third party
audit team uh may be given some
knowledge of the system that they are
assessing or testing. So the combined
approach
of these improves assurance and
identifies hidden vulnerabilities.
So risk analysis is to assess impact and
likelihood to prioritize the mitigation
and threat modeling identifies potential
attacks parts and system weaknesses.
So coming on to the database systems
that how we secure the system what are
some of the best practices to secure the
system. So database system security
overview database security extends
serverbased security principles.
So additional control on the database
depend on whether the database is
network accessible. So it is if it is
network accessible we may have more
control. If it is not network accessible
it is local. Then we may have different
approach for security of the database
system. So non- network database server
have fewer risk but still require
hardening.
So these are some of the best practices
uh for database security to follow CIS
database hardening guidelines. Install
and enable only needed component. This
as we studied this is also known as to
minimize the attack surface. The less
services are open ports you have, the
less attack service you have and the
less threats you have to the system.
Store data and logs on separate
partition. Set strict file permission on
database directory logs and
certificates. Run database under a
dedicated unprivilege account on a
dedicated server. Disable command
history and anonymous accounts and avoid
using environment variables or config
files for credentials.
So access control and authentication in
database system. So use TLS that is
transport layer security for all
connection and replication across
untrusted networks. Assign unique
certificates to each database instance.
Change default passwords and use strong
passwords or multiffactor
authentication.
Apply list privilege for user and admin
roles. Avoid default roles. Define
custom restricted roles per need and
remove unused or admin accounts. Use
unique admin accounts per person to
support separation of duties as well as
accountability.
So if you have named account after each
admin,
you know who is doing what.
Monitoring and auditing and based
system. So enable and centralize logging
for sensitive operations. Powered logs
to secure monitoring systems such as
steam.
Protect logs from tempering by database
admins. And so the seam gives you this
function. If the logs are automatically
forwarded to the seam solution, the
database admin won't be able to temper
with the logs because they won't have
access to the steam solution. Log
security incidents
with enough detail for forensic such as
uh with for forensic avoid passwords.
follow vendor specific security features
for example Oracle data dictionary
protection.
Now coming over to some uh an important
topic which is encryption approaches in
database system. So encrypting the uh
stored data is important but encrypting
data inside database uh requires
specific and special approaches and
these includes first one is the full
disk encryption which protects data on
the stolen or lost uh drives. So it
gives no protection from logical attacks
which is because the system auto
decrypts. What does this mean? This
means that when a database is accessed
by application, the data inside database
is automatically decrypted. So it does
not give logical attacks from you can
say application side.
Number two is file system level
encryption or you also sometime known as
fle.
So this encrypts at volume, directory or
file level. So this is again granular
level or lower level. Full discription
is uh encrypting the whole disk
including uh all the data file directory
etc. While in file level file system
level encryption you can encrypt uh the
data at file level as well as volume and
directory level. Next is the transparent
data decryption uh encryption or TDE
which protects against operating system
level access but again it does not
protect from SQL injection or database
admin abuse.
And now coming over to some advanced
encryption approaches and uh and the
fourth encryption uh type as well which
is cell level encryption or CL. This
encrypts data at the cell or column
level. You can say that this is the most
granular encryption level
because you are now uh encrypting data
at an individual cell or column inside
the table. Enable file grand fine grain
key control but adds complexity and
performance cost. Of course, if you are
encrypting data at such low level uh
granular level, it will hit the
performance as well as add to the
complexity.
And fifth is the application level
encryption. So encryption decryption
handled by application logic layer. So
database stores only encrypted binary
data and it is more secure but also
complex and can limit database function
for example searching inside the
database and encrypt as early as
possible and decrypt as late as
possible. So you should apply this
approach when using the application
level encryption.
So what are some uh encryption design
consideration in database systems? First
one is the performance. So the cell
level encryption may slow down the
queries because you are uh encrypting
encrypting each cell or you can say
column and rows.
Another consideration is the backups. So
protected under uh transparent data
encryption or cellular encryption FDE
may not protect backup. So when database
is encrypted using TDE or CL backups are
encrypted but if FDE or file system uh
level encryption the backups may not be
protected compression. So encrypted data
does not compress well and so consider
to decrypt first first decrypt the data
or the database then compress it and
then re-encrypt
re-encrypt it to uh avoid this scenario
but it also have the security because
you are decryting data. So you should
keep this in mind.
So now coming over to an important uh
topic of this domain which is
cryptographic systems overview. So all
cryptography
can eventually be broken. The question
is how much effort is required? So this
is an important quote by Bruce.
So what does this mean? This mean that
even if you use very strong encryption
or long keys, it can also be broken. But
it depends on uh how much resources you
have, how powerful computer you have and
how much time and effort you can take to
do the decryption. For example, now we
are talking about quantum computing and
one worry about the quantum computing is
that they can uh break the today's
encryption standard very easily because
they have immense power.
So attackers value of information versus
effort to break encryption. So if the
information is of high value they may
take uh they may uh give the effort to
break that encryption and if information
is of low value they won't do the effort
to break that encryption.
So what does this mean that if you have
very sensitive data you should use
strong encryption algorithm as well as
long encryption keys so that it requires
very huge effort uh or time to decrypt
that information. So vulnerability may
arise from uh encryption uh or
cryptographic algorithm as well as the
protocol weaknesses. How do you
implement them? As well as key
management vulnerabilities as we studied
if you use the HSM you may have less
vulnerabilities inside key management
but if you use simple uh some software
solution you may have key management
vulnerabilities.
So algorithm and protocol weaknesses are
to use you should use only algorithms
that are proven, reviewed and
standardized. For example, the AES
for encryption and char 2 for hashing.
Aide algorithm with known flaws are back
doors. For example, dual
EC DRBG.
An example of a weak algorithm or uh
compromised algorithm is WP which is
wired equivalent privacy used inside
Wi-Fi. It is uh weak 24bit and plus also
flawed
and it can be easily decrypted. So you
should never use such algorithm that are
proven to be weak and compromised.
So cryptography also weakens over time
due to increased computing power as we
were talking about quantum computing
improved crypt analysis methods and as
we said quantum computing threads. So
you should use life cycle management
that is reenrypt long lived data with
new standard. For example, if you had
stored some data and encrypted it with
the
D or data encryption standard, you
should reinccrypt that data now with the
AES which is more strong encryption
algorithm as compared to the uh desk
which was used in the past but is now
weak and compromised.
What are some implementation weaknesses?
So you should use trusted published
cryptographic libraries and never
selfdevelop. You should not use your own
developed because they may be weak. You
may never know. But the well trusted and
well tested public library should be
used. case study uh is the heart bleed
uh scenario where TLS heartbeat FL
I think heart bleed hard bleed flaw
leaked server memory including private
keys and it affected this much secure
websites.
There are some side channel attacks
which applied power consumption timing
to magnetic emissions. So when a server
is running
the power consumed by the server the uh
timing uh of these power consumption as
well as the electromagnetic waves
emitted by the server
uh the data from these can be used by
hackers to
uh deduce or infer the algorithm use or
other information.
Mitigation of these flaws include using
constant time comparisons to avoid loops
or lookups based on secular data using
cryptographic grade random number
generators and validate compiler
behavior.
So what are some key management
vulnerabilities? So always follow NIST
special publication 813
for key generation. Use key rotation and
avoid key reuse.
You should change the key and rotate
them uh frequently. Store keys securely
using key management software cloud KMS
and more importantly
the dedicated hardware security modules.
So protect against insider threats via
dual control and segregation of duties.
As we stated for example, you should not
give the complete key to one person.
Rather you can divide and give one
portion of key to let's suppose one
person and another part of portion of
key to
second person so that it takes at least
two person to do encryption or
decryption. Ensure availability of key
material, log key operations for
accountability and automate key
management to reduce human error. So the
tools are hardware security modes you
can say they are more secure
because they are less prone to error as
compared to manual human efforts. Our
next topic is industrial control system
or ICS overview. So industrial control
system automate industrial processes
such as manufacturing, utilities, power
and HVAC.
So focus on integrity, availability and
safety. Historically these systems are
isolated but now increasingly connected
to the network. So it means they are now
more exposed.
And some example of frameworks include
ISAIC 6243 which define secure
industrial control systems procedures.
Ncip which is mandatory for power
infrastructure inside US and Canada.
NIST SP800-82
which is a guide to securing an
industrial control system and
ERNCIP
which is EU's critical infrastructure
protection.
So some industrial control system
security challenges. First one is the
patching difficulties. So the industrial
control system are operate. They operate
continuously without any break. They are
uh almost uh located remotely at remote
sides. For example, sometime they may be
offshore and you cannot take risk of the
downtime.
They most often use the default
credential and they are often left
unchanged.
So they have a long life cycle as
compared to other IT systems such as
server and PC 10 to 20 years versus 3 to
5 years in IT systems
and air gap network not always reliable.
What does this mean? This means that the
industrial control system may be
airgapped. Air gap means that may they
may not be connected to the network or
to the internet but that does not
guarantee the security. An example is
the stucknet stuckset malware which was
used against Iranian centrifuge which
were of course air gap but the malware
was uh conveyed there or it reached the
Iranian certified through an infected
USB. So the air gap was breached through
a USB. A USB was connected to let's you
can say an engineer laptop and that
laptop was connected then to the
centrifuge network and the malware thus
spread spread to the this airgapped
network.
So what does this mean? This mean that
you should not only rely on the network
security but other connectivity such as
USB, the operating system, the software
that you are using uh air gap network as
well.
What are some best practices for
securing industrial control system? So
apply firmware and software updates uh
whenever feasible. Maintain strict
physical security for devices. Enforce
network segmentation and use firewalls
and proxies for remote access. Use VPNs
or web proxies. Use dedicated
maintenance systems.
So when uh no internet or personal use.
So the system that are used for the
maintenance for example the PC or
laptops they should not be your personal
system and they should never be
connected to the internet. Security
awareness training for operator and
technician which is important one
because remember humans are always the
weakest link in the security chain.
Our next topic is the distributed
systems. So distributed system are a
group of interconnected system that
operate together and appear as a single
unified system to users. An objective of
these systems are reliability because
they continually operate despite
failure, performance, optimized resource
utilization and scalability. They can
handle increased workload efficiently.
What are some security challenges of
these distributed systems? So they have
large attack surface due to multiple
interconnected subsystems. Encryption
andification needed between components
to prevent interception and spoofing.
Denial of service risk targeting
communication links or individual
subsystem. Inconsistency issue that is
split brain issue between different
system if communication between them is
disrupted. Heterogeneous environments
make patching and configuration
management harder. Geographical
distribution complicates applying
consistent physical and personal
security and data serverity and privacy
laws restrict crossborder data transfer.
Our next topic is the internet of thing
or IoT.
So IoT is a net of network of physical
devices such as sensor, appliances,
machines that are embedded with the
software that enable them to connect and
exchange data over the internet. So
nowadays almost all things are smart
such as uh
your car, your washing machine, your
refrigerator. These all things can be
part of internet of things. Example
include smart home devices, medical
sensor, router, CCTV cameras and
industrial controller.
So what are some IoT security principle
from manufacturers uh perspective?
So these are the thing that should be
done to conduct threat modeling during
design and development of uh these
internet of things to follow OASP and
SANS secure coding guidelines. Enforce
default password change before device
activation. Enable automatic firmware
updates.
Designed for secure initialization and
firmware integrity checks and balance
usability versus security is of use must
not mean ease of compromise.
So what are IoT security uh from users
perspective? Again to change default
credential before connecting the
internet of things devices to the
internet keep the firmware updated and
best thing is to enable auto updates or
you can also check it manually if this
is not possible.
Place all the IoT devices behind a
firewall and should not be directly
connected to the internet.
Segment the network means to isolate IoT
devices from other sensitive systems.
Use reverse network address translation
or proxy authentication for external
access and secure your router or proxy
that is to change the default
credentials and apply
vulnerability or security patches.
So key security principles uh include
defense in depth. As we already studied
defense depth means to apply multiple
layers of security such as firewall,
proxy and segmentation.
Least privileges restrict devices access
only to what's needed. And zero trust is
to do not rely on network location.
Authenticate every user and every device
even if they are trusted or your
internal devices.
Our next topic is microervices
architecture.
So it is a modular design approach where
an application is divided into
independent loosely coupled services
each running its own process and
communicating via lightweight protocol
for example REST APIs.
So it is in contrast with monolithic
architecture. In monolithic architecture
we have one single huge architecture. So
monolithic is one large single unit code
base. For example Microsoft office.
It is one uh application one software a
big one. And microservices are
independent modular services. For
example AWS architecture. In AWS we have
newness small services or modular
services.
What are some key security principles in
micro services? First one is isolation.
So each service should be independent,
deployable, modifiable and renewable
without affecting other services
and to contain vulnerability within one
service to prevent systemwide impact. As
we studied in micro segmentation or
segmentation the uh microservices since
each service is independent. So the
vulnerabilities or uh you can say
weaknesses in one service should be
limited to that and should not spread to
other services or systemwide.
Again defense in depth apply multiple
security layers at service and network
levels and protect both individual
microservices and their interervice
communication.
API security and gateway. So APIs are
the most vulnerable points in micro
service environments. So use an API
gateway to act as a single entry point
for all client request. Enforce
authentication rate limiting and input
validation via API gateway and hide
internal microservices behind a
firewall.
Next, our next topic is
containerization. So a container
packages an application and its
dependencies into a single lightweight
unit that runs consistently across
environment.
For example, the service or the
container package can be run on prem
inside cloud or both at cloud as well as
onrem.
So key point in contization is that it
uses the host operating system kernel
instead of a full operating system
unlike VM. So in virtualization or in uh
virtual machine each VM has its own
operating system. In containers, the
container package does not have its own
operating system. Rather than it uses
the host operating system kernel enables
fast, consistent and portable deployment
commonly managed using kubernetes and it
supports both monolithic and micro
service applications.
So what are some security concern in
containerization? First one is the
compromise of container images and
repositories. So use sign base images
from trusted sources. Apply
vulnerability scanning and patching and
maintain configuration management and
version control.
Number two is misuse of containers or
host compromise. So avoid running
containers with the privileged flag.
Apply rback or role-based access control
for image access. Secure the host
operating system and run only necessary
services and restrict container to
container communication.
That is the principle of least
privilege.
Another uh concept is the serverless
computing which is a cloud model where
the provider manages the server
automatically provisioning and scaling
resources as needed. The user focuses
only on writing and deploying the code
for example AWS Lambda Azour function
and Google cloud function.
So key benefits of the serverless
computing is that you don't do you don't
need to do any server management. So
cloud provider handles all the
provisioning, patching and scaling.
Ephemeral function mean that the uh they
are short led code execution reduces
attack persistence.
So the host environment is only uh
needed during the code execution.
So this reduces the attack persistence
or you can also say uh attack
probabilities
granular access control. So small code
bases allow tighter permission and
reduced customer responsibility. So the
provider handle operating system and
runtime security.
So what are some security concern in
serverless computing? First one is the
broken authentication. So weak or
misconfigured authentication mechanism
is a security risk over privilege
function excessive permissions and roles
complex attack surface. So multiple
interconnected functions increase the
exposure.
What are some best security practices in
serverless computing? First one is to
enforce least privilege. Grant each
function only necessary permission.
enforce code integrity, scan for
vulnerabilities and configuration
issues, enable runtime protection. So
this uh detect anomalies, errors or
suspicious events and use provider and
third-party security tools to leverage
AWS Azure, a Google Cloud Platform
built-in monitoring and external
solutions for added defense.
Our
next topic is embedded systems. So
embedded systems are specialized
computing components within larger
mechanical or electrical system
performing dedicated function. For
example, in cars, ATMs, routers, medical
devices or
appliances.
Common uses of embedded system include
they are used in domestic appliances
such as TVs, refrigerator, washing
machine in office equipment such as
printers, scanner inside network devices
such as routers, firewall, automobiles,
uh ATM, medical devices and industrial
systems.
So some attack surfaces and examples in
embedded system. So these are the uh
types then the description example of
the attack and how to mitigate them.
So attacks related to the user interface
is that manipulating the controls or
hidden administrative functions uh
functions. An example attack on user
interface could be pressing button
sequences to unlock specific features
and mitigation include the firmware
review and fuzz testing.
Next is the physical so tampering with
the device casing or service ports. An
attack example include exploiting a
voting machine via its management ports
and mitigation is tempering detection,
strong locks and epoxy.
Next is the uh sensor
and description is to interfere with the
input sensor. Example attacks include
skimmers or shimmers on card reader,
Tesla key, de relay attacks and
mitigation includes sensor hardening,
encryption and shielding.
Next type is the output which is
controlling the actuators directly.
Example attack include forcing door
locks open via power injection and
mitigation include secure cabling
physical protection and last one is the
processor which is direct chip access or
firmware manipulation and example attack
include loading rug firmware onto the
processor and mitigation include signed
firmware encryption and updateation.
So what are some security considerations
for the embedded system
and they are to use digitally signed
firmware to prevent unauthorized update
that is to preserve the integrity of the
embedded system firmware. Apply
cryptography to protect firmware and its
communication. Implement temper evident
and temper resistant designs. We are
talking about physical tempering with
the embedded system and plain form
firmware upgradability or add
compensating control if patching is not
feasible. So it is recommended that you
upgrade firmware regularly and if this
uh firmware upgradation is not possible
then you need to add some compensating
control and these may include installing
a firewall in front of the uh embedded
system
uh segmentation network segmentation
etc.
Our
next and important topic is now
cryptography. So what are initially some
core cryptography definitions? So these
will be used uh throughout our upcoming
slides uh about cryptography.
So going go going through quick
definitions of these term. Plain text is
the original readable message such as
these slides. It is a plain text. it is
not encrypted not 012 or something like
that you can make sense of these reading
so it is a plain text clear text is the
readable message not meant to be
encrypted so let's suppose this I
transfer this message to someone without
encrypting it uh then we can say that I
send the message in clear text okay I
hope this is understandable number three
is cipher track cipher text which is
encrypted unreadable form of the
message. For example, if I encrypt this
message, these two lines using the AES
encryption,
then it will result something like
this you can say and it won't make any
sense. They are unreadable messages that
you encrypted. Encryption is the process
of converting this plain text into
cipher text. Decryption is process of
converting cipher text to plain text.
Cryptographic algorithm is made function
used for encryption decryption. So when
we do encryption and decryption, we do
it through cryptographic algorithm such
as this one. AES is example of a
cryptographic algorithm. E is the secret
value controlling the cryptographic
algorithm. So when we encrypt uh the
messages or text or uh data then we use
the algorithm plus a key length. For
example, we may use 256
bit key length and this secret key is
the you can say the secret sauce that do
the magic. you can reveal everything the
cryptography algorithm
uh the
everything else about the these all uh
encryption function but you need to keep
secret only one thing and you will be
good and that is your key. We are
talking about the symmetric key or in
public key cryptography the private key
it should always be secure. If it is
revealed then everything is uh all these
encryption algorithm and your data is
then can be easily decrypted using this
key.
Next is the key cryptographic life cycle
considerations. So what are some
consideration during cryptography life
cycle? First one is the al algorithmic
uh algorithm selection. So we have
multiple type of cryptography algorithm.
It may be symmetric which uses same key
for encryption decryption. So we will
study these in detail in the upcoming
slides. Asymmetric is the public key
cryptography which in which we have two
uh keys. One is public, one is private.
And then hashing is a one-way
cryptographic function in which we
convert
uh a variable length of data into a
fixed length of hash. It is mainly used
for integrity as we already studied. So
some uh cryptographic algorithm examples
such as AES which is a symmetric
algorithm, RSA is asymmetric, SHA is
example of hashing etc. Another thing
that is used as I already told in
previous slides is the key length. For
example, AES-256
means that we have a key length of 256
bit. RSA-2048
means that we are using a key length of
2048 bit. So these are important
considerations when using cryptography
when selecting cryptography
uh process.
So use cases of the cryptography. So
symmetric encryption is used uh it is
fast. So you can say it is used when we
have very large amount of data or bulk
data because it can encrypt it fast. It
is good for data at rest encryption and
in transit as well but required secure
key exchange.
What does this mean? This means that
since in symmetric key we have same key
for encryption as well as decryption.
So we if we have a party A and a party B
and party A want to send a message to B
then the first thing to consider is how
to send that same symmetric key to B
because if party A encrypt message with
a key let's suppose key one the same key
must be used by party B to decrypt it.
So how do we exchange it? We will study
this in the upcoming side. This is an
important consideration. This
consideration is not required in public
key cryp cryptography.
Uh we will uh uh how it is done in
public key. We will study this also in
the upcoming slides. So hashing is a
one-way function
for passwords, data verification and no
decryption needed.
One way means that you only you can say
encrypt or change the your data into a
hash but it is not reversible. You do
not decrypt that back or you do not
reverse that hash back to the original
data. Then how does we use hashing?
We compare the two hashes. For example,
you are sending a message.
message one you take a hash of this
let's suppose hash one
and you send it to let's suppose a party
B
you also send the message in
let's suppose you can say in plain text
are encrypted to party B the party B
then hash the message again let's
suppose here is hash taken by party B
hash2 and then the party B compares this
hash H that it received as well as the
hash taken by the party B from the
original message. If they both are equal
then it means the message is original.
It is not tempered with it is not
alterated and that how the hashing
works. We will study about it in detail.
Tokenization is replacing sensitive data
like uh pen with tokens to
reduce exposure. So as we studied in our
I think uh domain number one
tokenization is when we
have personally identifiable information
and we want to make it uh confidential
we can replace the sensitive data with
tokens.
Number third consideration is the
performance and constraint. So let's
suppose for internet of thing and edge
devices these devices has very low
processing power. So we need lightweight
cryptography algorithms hardware
support. So some CPUs such as Intel, AMD
or ARM they accelerate specific
algorithms like AES they had built-in
algorith uh acceleration for specific
algorithm. So you can need to consider
these things in mind. Key length
tradeoff. So longer the key, more is the
security but also it requires greater
processing power and so your overall
performance will be slow if you use
longer key length. So you need to have a
tradeoff between security as well as
performance
blocks versus stream fiber. So these are
two types of
uh cipher how you do encrypt data. So
block ciphers encrypt fixsized blocks.
For example, AES they encrypt data in
fixed bulks or sizes and it is commonly
used for data at rest. Stream fiber
encrypt data bit by bit and it is common
for realtime communication such as for
serial communication you can say. Fifth
consideration is the mode of operation
of the cryptographic algorithm. It may
be ECB that is electronic code book.
This is simple but insecure because it
reveals patterns. For example, if you
have same type of text let's suppose
hello,
it will always result in same type of
you can say encrypted
data. So it reveals pattern which is
unsecure. CBC that is cipher
blockchaining. It is more secure because
it uses initialization vector and due to
this initialization vector same text
does not always result in same encrypted
data.
Next is the cyber feedback.
So it turns block cipher into stream
power. So for example if you have block
cipher the cipher feedback basically
turns turns it into uh you can say
stream fiber.
So some important principles first one
is the cryptographic agility algorithms
can become weak over time. For example
the dash rc4 and sha shiaan these are
these have become weaker over time and
nowadays they are insecure and
duplicated. They cannot be used anymore.
Key management is critical for security.
It includes generation, exchange,
storage, rotation and destruction of
keys and data lifetime is the long-term
archival may require stronger keys and
algorithm. So for example, if you need
to archive the data for a long term, you
should use stronger keys and algorithm
because as we studied in our as we said
in our first principle, algorithms also
become weak over time. So you should use
strong algorithm so that they test the
time period.
Cryptographic methods overview. So what
are some cryptographic methods or
cryptographic algorithms important
topic? So the purpose is to protect
confidentiality, integrity and
authenticity of data. The purpose of
cryptography.
So what are some use cases and which
type of cryptography
cryptographic
uh method is used? First use case is
let's suppose confidentiality of stored
data
we need and we use as we studied in
previous slide for data at rest or for
stored data we use we use symmetric
encryption. It is strong. It is fast.
Confidentiality of data in transit.
Again we use symmetric for data
encryption. We also use asymmetric along
with symmetric but this one is mainly
used for key exchange. As we
studed in our previous slide that in
symmetric we have we need to have same
key for encryption as well as
decryption. So how do we exchange the
key securely? It is done to through the
asymmetric algorithm. So symmetric is
used for the data encryption along with
asymmetric for the key exchange. So we
can say that we use the hybrid approach.
Identity verification is done through
the public key infrastructure or PKI.
Data integrity. For data integrity, we
need we use hashing and message
authentication code. For password
protection, we use hashing with salt and
pepper.
So, as we studied in the previous
example, if we we don't use salt with
hashing, same password will always
result in same type of hash which is
vulnerable to different types of attack
such as uh rainbow table attack. For
example, if your password is 1 2 3 and
you take a hash of it, the hash I'm
giving just an example without salt this
hash this password is always in same
hash.
So it is vulnerable if uh the attacker
get hold of the hashes of the messages.
It can easily be deduced that which type
of passwords are being used. And if you
use salt and pepper with the hash, same
password will not result in same hash
each time. Because besides this
password, salt means let's suppose a
true random number is added with let's
suppose 1
4 6 ABC.
This is a s that is added and so it will
result in something
else.
Non-repudiation means that if a user or
system performs certain action, it
should be make made certain that they uh
later they cannot deny having performed
the action and it is done through
digital signature.
So now coming over to the different
encryption algorithm. First one is
symmetric. These slides are important.
So symmetric algorithm or symmetric
encryption uses same key for encryption
as well as decryption. It is fast and
efficient for bulk data. These are very
important for from exam point of view.
You should keep this in mind that it is
fast and since it is fast it can be used
for bulk data encryption.
Example of symmetric encryption uh
include dash, triple dash, aes and rc
algorithm. So dash uh uh is no longer
used. Triple dash is also not
recommended. The recommended standard
for encryption uh AES or for symmetric
encryption is as advanc encryption
standard.
But as we already studied for symmetric
key one important consideration is to
securely share the symmetric key between
the two parties and for this we then use
asymmetric or public key encryption.
So symmetric encryption may be stream or
block cipher. So in stream fiber uh the
symmetric key encrypts data uh in bit by
bit or by by bit using key stream for
example an example of stream cipher
symmetric stream cipher is RC4 and its
use case is to encrypt data in real time
and low CPU uh and it is used in low CPU
devices
cyber as we studed It encrypts fixed
size blocks for example AES and S and it
is used for file encryption and VPN or
virtual private network.
So what are some common symmetric
encryption algorithms
and these include dash data encryption
standard key size uh is 56 bit but this
is obsolete deprecated and should not be
used anymore. Triple dash is uh key size
may be from 112 to 168 bit again it is
also duplicated and should not be used.
The go-to standard is AES advanced
encryption standard. Key size may be
128, 192 or 256. And it is the current
standard. RC2, RC2 and RC4 key size is
variable. It is also insecure and should
not be used. RC5 and RC6 again their key
size or key length is variable. it is
secure and RC6 was basically the
finalist
for uh during the compet selection of
AES or you can say it is as become
strong as AES.
So our next important encryption type is
asymmetric encryption also known as
public key cryptography and this one
solves the key distribution problem of
symmetric key encryption. So this is
important point keep this in mind.
Asymmetric encryption or public key
cryptography uses two keys. Public key
is used and shared openly and private
key is kept secret.
So if you encrypt data with the public
key only private key can decrypt it. So
it gives you the confidentiality.
And if uh for example you can also use
this for encryption. For example, your
public key is with everyone. They can
send you data encrypted with public key
and only you can decrypt it because only
you have the private key. On the other
hand, if you encrypt data with your
private key, again it can be decrypted
with the public key, everyone can
decrypt it. Then how does we can use
this this functionality for
authentication and nonrepudiation. It
means that since only you have the
private key, if the data is decryptable
with public key, it means it must be
sent by you. The other case is that your
private key is lost or compromised.
So it is used for authentication
non-repudiation
based on mathematical trap door
function. Easy one way hard to reverse.
So there is a mathematical uh pro uh
calculation behind this asymmetric uh
encryption.
So that's why uh it is uh easy one way
but hard to reverse. These are uh
mathematical formula
using the logarithmic uh calculation
uh and uh prime numbers etc to calculate
the private and public key and how they
interact with each other.
Some common asymmetric algorithms
include RSA and RSA is used for
encryption as well as digital
signatures. As we studied the digital
signatures are used for authenticity
and it is based on as I said factoring
large prime numbers and it is most
widely public key in algorithm used.
Next is the Deffy Halman Merkel and it
is used for key exchange and it uses
discrete uh logorithm and it generates
shared symmetric key. So as we studied
that public key uh in public key
cryptography is used for symmetric key
sharing on symmetric key exchange. So it
is basically the defy helman Merkel
algorithm that is used for generating
the symmetric shared key and sharing
with the parties. Algamel is used for
digital signatures and key exchange and
it is derived from defy helman. It is
slower but flexible. ECC important one
electric curve cryptography. It is used
for encryption, signatures and key
exchange and it is based on electric
curve math. So it has smaller keys but
faster performance. So as we studied in
in our previous slides that for internet
of thing or edge devices as well as you
can also say embedded
systems.
These systems has low
resources or you can say low processing
power. So for this system it is
recommended that you use ECC because
they are faster having faster
performance with smaller fees. So this
is an important point to keep in mind
and to remember. If you come across a
question in your exam and you are given
multiple let's suppose these four
algorithm and you are asked about which
algorithms uh
will be would suit best to be used for
IoT edge or embedded system then your
answer should be ECC or electric car
cryptography.
So ECC advantages are that they have
smaller key size but faster uh smaller
key size with strong uh security. So
that's why they their computation is
faster and it is efficient for mobile
IoT and low power system as I already
said. So for example 256 bit ECC is
almost equal to 3072bit
RSA in strength. So that's a huge
different in key length but they have
the same strength.
So in summary asymmetric encryptions
enable secure communication without
sharing the secret key. Public key
infrastructure manages key and
certificates and often combined the
public key encryption is often combined
with symmetric encryption in real world
system for performance that is hybrid
encryption because public key encryption
is used for key exchange while symmetric
encryption is actually used for the
actual data encryption
quantum cryptography. So it is a
cryptographic method that leverages the
laws of quantum mechanics to ensure
secure key exchange and detect dropping.
What is quantum key distribution? It
uses quantum particles like photons to
transmit secure keys. Any interception
disturbs the quantum state revealing the
use dropping. So now it is very easy
using the quantum cryptography that if a
key is intercepted the quantum states
changes and it can be easily revealed
that the key was intercepted. If
interception is detected the key is
discarded and a new one is generated.
Once a secure key is confirmed data is
encrypted using symmetric encryption or
one-time pads. So why it is so powerful?
It is because security is now based on
laws of physics not mathematics and it
is immune to future computational power
and quantum computer-based attacks. So
the current cryptographic algorithm that
are based on mathematics they both are
prone to computational power as well as
quantum computer based attacks.
So postquantum cryptography that is
quantum safe cryptography. So with
quantum computers emerging classical
algorithm like RSA ECC may be broken.
Quantum safe quantum safe cryptography
uses new mathematical approaches
resistant to quantum attacks. HCQSC that
is quantum safe cryptography group
develops standards for future proof
security.
So summary of the quantum cryptography.
So quantum cryptography uses quantum
mechanics for secure communication and
its key advantage is that it detects
dropping because if intercepted the
quantum state is changed and so it is
easily detected. The interception is
detected. Quantum key distribution is
used for secure key exchange and key
advantage that intrusion is easily
detected. Quantum safe cryptography
protect against quantum computers and it
is for future resilience.
Our next important topic is PKI or
public key infrastructure. So PKI
provides a trusted framework to manage,
distribute and verify public keys
ensuring that a public key truly belongs
to the claimed entity.
So how does PKI work? So this is uh we
will uh explain it with this example. So
step one is let's suppose Ellis creates
a certificate signing request or CSR to
the CA which contains her identity plus
her public key and it is signed with her
private key. So since Ellis private key
is only with Ellis, it makes sure that
the public key actually belongs to her.
So this is what the CSR contain. It is
sent to CA. In step two, the uh CA
basically verifies LS identity based on
LS public key which was
which was encrypted with or signed with
her private key. And the C assigns and
issues a digital certificate binding her
identity to her own public keys.
And now finally Bob which is a third
party or another user uh if Bob trusts
CA it means therefore Bob trusts Ellis
certificate and public key. So this
whole method this whole concept is based
on CA's trust. If CA is trusted, so are
other people, other individual, other
parties that have received certificates
from the same CA.
So X509 digital certificate structure.
So you can say this is the certificate
that is issued by CA and this
certificate includes the version and
serial number of the certificate.
Signature algorithm that is used uh for
signing the certificate.
PNM which CA issue the certificate
validity period of the certificate. The
owner subject or the owner and the
public key usage and extension and CA's
own digital signature. So CA digital
signature is used to verify the CA.
What are some uh certificate types
inside the PKI? So it may be personal or
organizational which is used for email,
code signing and identity. An example is
digital certificate of a specific user.
Another certificate type is a
certificate of the web server which is
used for TLS/SSL
uh cryptography. It is used to secure
websites such as HTTPS uh security and
an example of the website may be anyone
such as www.google.com google.com
and another certificate type is the
self-signed certificate which is
internal or for test environments and it
is uh can be used inside an organization
on internet
so inside organization each entity trust
another one so the internal certificate
or self-signed certificate can be used
inside the organization own network or
internet
so this is a cert certificate trust
chain. So root CA to intermediate CA and
to the end entity such as website or
individual certificate. So the root key
is kept offline and only used to sign
intermediate CS browser trust
certificate issued by
vetted CS.
So certificate validation methods
include CRL which is certificate
revocation list and this is browser
based uh browser download list of re
revocated certificate. So this is you
can say
an old method where the browser would
download all the revoked certificate
list. It would be a long list.
Another efficient method is OCSP which
is align certificate status protocol. It
is real time and it shows good, revoked
or unknown uh status check of the
certificates
and you can also uh use the validation
method of pin or internal list. It is
used by some browsers such as Chrome for
faster validation.
So take away key takeaways from the PKI
is that PKI is equal to trust plus
verification plus ver uh revocation.
So PKI first it is built on based on
trust trust of CAS trust of CS
certificate then it has the verification
method of the certificate and finally if
uh a certificate is no longer used or it
is compromised it is revoked and it has
a uh certificate verification method
such as these security depends on
keeping private keys secret for both the
user as well as the CA compromised keys
are untrusted CAS are potential for man
in the middle attacks. So certificate
check ensure the trust inheritance.
So what are digital signatures and
digital certificates important topic. So
the purpose of digital signature is to
provide authentication, integrity and
nonrepudiation.
So digital signatures basically do not
ensure confidentiality. For
confidentiality we use encryption.
Digital signature only provide
authentication
of a user, integrity of message and
nonrepudiation
of uh user or systems.
So how does digital uh signatures work?
So first the message is hashed to
provide a message digest using a hashing
algorithm. For example, you can use
uh SH 2.
Then the hash message is encrypted with
the sender's private key and this
constitutes the digital signature. So
digital signature is the hashed message
and encrypted with the you can say the
private key of the owner. This
constitute the digital signature. So
when the digital signature is received
by the receiver,
it again hashes the received message
again. So uh at the receiver end both
the message as well as the digital
signature are sent. It decrypts the
digital signature using the sender's
public key and then it compares both the
digest digest that was received uh
through this uh signature.
When decrypted
using the public key, the hash message
is received and hash of the uh message
received is also taken. Both they are
compared and if they mage it means
message is authentic and unaltered.
Trust and verification. So receiver must
trust the sender's public key and trust
is established by direct key exchange or
certificate authority as we studied
verifying the identity via digital
certificate.
The best practice is to use the private
key only for signing and not for message
encryption.
What are some vulnerabilities inside
digital signature? these maybe hash
collisions which means when two messages
produce the same digest. So ideally each
message should result in a different
digest but if two messages two different
data messages or text messages produce
same digest it means we have a hash
collision.
Private key disclosure if private key is
compromised it invalidates the
authenticity and CA compromise. So it
allows attackers to scoop identities and
forge signatures if the CA is
compromised.
So how to mitigate these
vulnerabilities?
Use strong hash algorithms.
Protect private keys and revoke
compromised ones through add them into
CRL. Trust only reputable and secure PS
nonrepudiation.
Non-repudiation ensures that a message
or transaction cannot be denied by the
sender pro proving it originated from a
specific entity. It means it provides or
ensures authenticity that a message is
sent by a specific user and that user
cannot deny that he or she sent the
message. So it is essential for
contracts, legal documents, banking and
supplier orders. So how do we ensure the
non-repudiation? It is how it is
achieved. So the originator signs the
message with their private key. Remember
the private key is always with its owner
only. The recipient verifies using the
public key public key of the sender
or public key of the originator
confirming the sender's identity.
Private key potential is protection is
crucial. Compromise
destroys
non-repudiation. So if the private key
is lost, it means non-repudiation can no
longer be insured. So here as we saw
that if the user signs the message with
the private key
it can only be decrypted sign means uh
it is encrypted with the private key it
can only be decrypted with the public
key of the
this private key pair. So if this is the
party A, this is party B. Party A signs
the message with uh his private key, it
can only be decrypted with the public
key of the same private key pair that is
the party A public key. And if it is
decrypted, it means it uh proves that
the message was indeed signed or sent by
the party A.
So risk with the non-repudiation are
that private key disclosure which allows
attackers to forge messages and fake
money transfers
and PKI compromise attackers proof
trusted identities. For example, an
incident of DG notar which is which was
a CA and whose uh certificate were
compromised and then attacker use them
to uh proof identity.
So how to mitigate these risk? Use
trusted timestamps as per RFC 3161 from
a timestamping authority that is TSA to
prove when a message was signed.
promptly revoke compromised keys and
trust only secure certificate
authorities or CAS
blockchain and non-repudiation. So
blockchain is a decentralized
temper resistant ledger secured by
cryptographic hashes. Any change
requires altering all subsequent blocks
making forgery nearly impossible. Used
for traceability and accountability
industries like supply chain management
for example it is used by the code.
Integrity. So how do we ensure integrity
through cryptography? Integrity ensures
that data has not been altered or
tampered with. A key component of the
CIA triads. I is for the integrity. So
how integrity is verified?
Apply a hash to a message to to generate
the hash or you can call it hash1.
Recalculate a hash of the same message
later and compare it with a H1. So the
hash is again calculated when the
message is sent and received at the
receiver end. If both the hashes are
equal, it means the data is unchanged.
If not, it means the data was tampered
during transit or transfer
integrity. So check sum versus
cryptographic H. What is the difference
between them? So check some are simpler
math function. For example, sum of byes.
Cryptographic hashes are complex and it
is based on oneway algorithm.
Exum basically detect accidental errors
while cryptographic detects intentional
temporary tempering as well as
uh other transport transitional or
transportational
uh alteration as well.
Uh checksum is easy to forge. Attacker
can recalculate the check sum but
cryptographic hash are extremely hard to
for forge or find collusion. What does
this mean? This mean it is very
difficult to calculate the same hash
from a different message or to
guess the message from the hish because
it is irreversible. It is one way. You
can transform a message to a hash. But
you cannot
go backward. You cannot convert the hash
to the message.
An example of check sum is loan
algorithm for credit card. While example
of hashes are sh 3 and sha 2 5 12.
So hash collision as we studied it
occurs when two different messages
produce the same hash. MD5 is now
considered cryptographically broken due
to collision vulnerabilities. So MD5
should no longer be used. The secure
option are SHA 3, SHA 512 etc.
What is HMAG? That is hash message
hashbased message authentication code.
So hmag basically adds a secret key to
the hash process.
So in this way it verifies both the
integrity of the message as well as
authenticity
or the origin of the message.
So HMAC is used in TLS transport layer
security and IP security VPNs. It still
requires key sharing between sender and
receiver.
Because in symmetric method the receiver
and sender both have the same key.
So what's the difference between digital
signature and HMAC? So HMAC uses shared
secret key while digital signature uses
uh private and public key pair.
HDMAC provides integrity plus
authentication while digital signature
provides integrity authentication and
non-repudiation.
HMAC is lightweight and no PKI is needed
to implement it while digital signature
requires PKI and has more overhead.
So now coming out our another important
topic methods of crypt analytic attacks.
What are some attacks that are carried
out against cryptography? The first one
is the brute force where attacker tries
all possible keys until the correct one
is found. And defense against brute
force is to use longer keys length. For
example, AES
128.
You can use a longer one. AES 192 or
256.
Password protection. Use slow hashing
that is PBKDF2
brypt and salting to defeat precomputed
attacks that is rainbow table. So as we
already studied in our previous slides
that when we use salt and pepper with
password
it means that our hashes
for the same password even if two user
has the same password their hashes will
be different due to thought and paper
and thus we can protect against the
rainbow tables attacks.
Cypher text only attack where attacker
only has encrypted data and tries to
deduce the key or plain text for example
web which is uh which was previously
used in Wi-Fi wired equivalent privacy
is vulnerable due to weaknesses in RC4
stream cipher to defense against uh the
cipher text only attack is to use strong
encryption algorithm such as the latest
standard WPA3 in Wi-Fi.
Number three is the nonplane
uh text attack which is when attacker
knows part of the plain text and its
corresponding cipher text. For example,
German enigma known phrases helped break
the code inside World War II.
So defense against such attack is to
avoid predictable
plain text patterns.
Number four is chosen plain text attack.
When attacker, it is the type of attack
when attacker can submit plain text and
get its cipher text. For example, World
War II Midway AF message test.
So this was the message sent
intentionally in uh clear text you can
say by the Allied forces. It was then
received by the German forces and uh
sent through their enigma machine in
encrypt uh encrypted way. So when the
encrypted message was received the uh
cipher text for AFR reduced and thus
they were able to break the uh German
enigma. So defense against them is to
use modern algorithms with randomized
encryption.
Number five is chosen cyber cipher tax
attack is when attacker can submit
cipher tax and obtain plain text. For
example
uh this attack lan baker attack on SSL
3.0 which is an RSA vulnerability and
defense against it is to use updated TLS
version and constant time error
responses.
And number six is frequency analysis
which exploits character frequency
patterns and it is useful in
substitution ciphers and defense against
it to use modern ciphers with no
character correlation.
And number seven is implementation
attacks which exploit flaws in software
or hardware in implementation not the
algorithm itself and defense against is
to follow secure coding and patching
practices.
Number eight is side channel attacks.
In this attack the attacker derive
information from timing power use cache
or electromagnetic emission. Example
include spectre and meltdown that is
casher timing and defense I guess it is
to use constant time algorithm and
shielding.
Number nine is fault injection. So in
this type of attack it uh intestinal
hardware or software errors are injected
to reveal the key data and defense is to
add error checking and redundant
verification. Number 10 is timing
attacks which analyze encryption
decryption time to infer keys. Defense
is to implement iso isocchronous that is
constant time processing regarded
regardless of the key length
and number 11 is maninthe- middle
attack. So the attacker intercepts and
alters communication between two
parties. Example is DG notar
certification authority compromised in
2011 and defense is to use valid digital
certificates PKI and certificate pinning
and number 12 is pass the hash where
attacker reuse a stolen password hash to
authenticate and defense is to use least
privilege password rotation and
multiffactor authentication.
Number 13 is Keraros exploitation where
attackers forge or reuse tickets known
as pass the ticket attacks and defense
is to use multiffactor authentication
monitor active directory logs and
enforce strong passwords. Number 14 is
ransomware where malware. Ransomware is
the malware that encrypts files inside
your computer or server and demands
ransom for the decryption key. Defense
is to maintain offline backups, apply
patches and use this privileges as well
as update the anti-malware.
So our next topic is the site and
facility designs. We are talking about
physical facility that houses your
infrastructure such as your data center
and the core principles uh for the site
and facility design are to apply CIA
triad even to your physical environment.
So confidentiality/ integrity it
prevents unauthorized access theft and
tempering with your IT equipment.
Availability is uh availability
principle prevents downtime from
environmental
uh disaster such as fire, flood and
earthquake and infrastructure
disaster such as power or Hback failures
events.
Also apply risk management.
Risk management mitigation techniques as
we studied may be to avoid the risk
which is to choose low risk location for
your facility or design. For example,
uh you can choose a location that is not
prone to earthquakes, tornadoes etc. so
that you can avoid uh such physical
natural disaster. Mitigate is to apply
physical controls such as you can apply
the physical access control. You can
apply guards. You can apply biometrics
so that only authorized personnel can
enter the facility. Transfer is to use
insurers or vendor contracts to secure
your facility and accept is the residual
risk within the tolerance.
wiring closets and intermediate
distribution facilities. So secure, you
should secure the wiring closets and
intermediate distribution facilities
from unauthorized or accidental access.
So avoid the wiring closets uh loc avoid
locating them near pipes, HVAC or
electrical equipment.
Use rags and shielding against water and
electromagnetic interference. Ensure
proper ventilation to prevent
overheating of the equipment and protect
network alarm and door lock cabling that
extend beyond controlled areas.
How to protect server rooms and data
centers? So adds four main risk areas
that is the physical access to the
server room and data center. HVAC and
utilities, environmental threats and
fire risk.
Implement controls for personnel. You
should always uh do the background check
of the employees before onboarding and
before hirings.
You should do their training and you
should uh regularly monitor the excess
labs to your facilities. Maintenance
routine testing of the HVAC as well as
other infra facilities such as
generator, UPS and fuel should be done.
Monitoring and auditing continuous
logging and alerting of all the physical
access to your facility.
So refer to these standards when
implementing these s and facility
controls.
So next is the media storage
facilities. So always maintain
temperature and humidity control, air
filtration and anti-static
flooring. Avoid magnetic fields and
allow media to climate before use. So
media means by media storage facility
means that our backup location where we
store
our let's suppose storage area network
maybe we store our HDDs
such as these. So as we study that mag
uh magnetic disc drive are uh can their
data can be erased when exposed to
strong magnetic field. So you should
avoid magnetic field near these
facilities. Implement tracking and dual
authorization for media handling. Use
fire detection and suppression, proper
housekeeping and dedicated storage
areas.
Consider offsite storage for disaster
recovery and enforce media sanitization
and destruction before disposal such as
regassing. If you have the uh magnetic
disc drive
evidence storage, how to protect the
evidence storage facility? So, maintain
chain of custody with temper
proof
log books.
Restricted access policies. video
monitoring maybe motion on sensor based
dual log or dual control system. So the
purpose is to ensure authenticity and
integrity of evidence for legal use
restricted and work area security. So it
is designed based on risk assessment and
threat modeling and applies principle of
least privilege need to know separation
of duties dual control
defense in depth and compliance
obligations.
So it more directly impacts employees
and daily operations.
So now coming over to this principle
lease privilege and need to know means
that access be granted only as necessary
for job duties and based on formally
approved policies. Excess rights must be
reviewed regularly and maintain
auditable records of access decision and
reviews.
Separation of duties and door controls
for sensitive areas require two or more
authorized individuals for access
enforced via administrative control for
example guard log surveillance review
technical control such as dual lock
multiffactor access system and reduce
insider threat and fraud basic
defense in depth means to use layered
security zones for example Example, you
can divide the area into public area
which is exterior lobby or reception.
Low security is general office space and
high security areas or data center labs
or restricted room. Each transition
between these zones should require
authentication. For example, reception
verification, access badge pin and
biometric scanning. So the stricter the
zone, the stronger the authentication
required.
So the utilities and HVAC so power and
HVAC system are critical to data center
reliability. Both must be designed from
a risk assessment perspective with
redundancy testing and maintenance plans
and these are the power redundancy
level. These are different tiers and
this is their availability rating. So
tier one has 99.671
availability
and it has no redundancy and include
multiple single points of failure. Tier
2 has 99.741
availability and it has partial
redundancy known as N UPS. Tier 3 has
99.982%
availability.
It has n +1 UPS configuration means it
allows maintenance without downtime and
tier 4 the highest tier has 99.995%
availability and it has 2 n UPS and has
full redundancy and there is no single
point of failure.
So N here stands for sufficient units
for full load. So n + one means one
extra for maintenance or failure which
is tier three and 2 n means that we have
fully redundant independent system for
each UPS we have a redundant UPS so that
if one fails the other will continue to
provide the necessary power.
So power some power consideration UPS
types may be battery based which varies
by load capacity filtering and
reliability and they may be flywheel
based which is better for high loads
greater than 200 kilowatt and short-term
reliability.
So generators provides long-term backup
during power loss. So remember UPS is
for shortterm
power provision during uh generator
switchover while the generator are for
long-term power outages and they run on
diesel, gasoline, natural gas or
hydrogen and must be tested under full
road regularly.
What are some lesson learned? So avoid
single point of failure. For example, uh
never use a single generator. There
should be at least two so that if one
generator fails, the other can be used
to provide the necessary power test for
real life duration, not just short runs
and identify external dependency. For
example, cooling water,
cooling and humidity. So maintain
redundant cooling units n +1 or higher.
Prevent rapid temperature changes.
For example, the temperature change
should be less than or equal to five in
an hour. The tapes are less than equal
to 20 centrade per hour without tapes.
Control humidity. Low humidity produce
static discharge risk and high humidity
as the condensation risk.
Maintenance best practices include
schedule maintenance and full load test
fall detection and alerting system
periodic to ensure reliability.
The environmental issues include natural
internal wildlife warming or pandemic.
So the natural may be storm, earthquake,
floods, fire and mitigation includes
side selection area, building design and
disaster recovery plan. Internal may be
leaks, bust pipes, condensation
and mitigation include equipment
placement and drip canopies. Wildlife
warming include cable damage and short
circles and mitigation include sealed
cabling and regular inspection. and
pandemic uh example is the workforce
unavailability and mitigation include
remote work, flexible staffing and
hygiene policy.
So fire prevention, detection and
suppression. So fire principles are that
fire needs heat, fuel, oxygen and
chemical reaction
are also known as fire tetrahedron.
So suppression of fire removes one or
more of these element. For example, if
oxygen is removed,
fire fire won't be able to go on. So you
should the
purpose of fire suppression is to remove
any of these elements. So fire
suppression systems types description
and pro and cons. So the wet pipe
sprinkles
they uh the pipes are always filled with
water in this type of separation system
and uh their pros and cons are that pros
are they are low cost and their cons are
that they have the risk of water damage.
Dry pipe pipe separation system are that
water are released only when triggered
and it is for colder environment and a
con is that it has a delayed response as
compared to wet pipe sprinkler.
Deluge is all heads are open and uh it
releases large amount of water and is
used in industrial areas.
reactions are requires both detection
and heat and it reduces accidental
discharge. Water mist are fine droplets,
less water damage
and it is better for electronics
and some clean agents for fire
separation systems are CO2 helon HF-27
EA. So gas basically displaces oxygen or
stops chemical reaction and it has no
residue. It is costly and has safety
consideration for humans.
So fire extinguisher use correct
extinguisher type wrong one uh use can
worsen fire or endanger staff. So these
are the classes they are important to
remember. Class A is for solid
materials such as woods, paper and
plastic fires.
You can remember A from ash. So these
are the things that produce ash and for
this we use class A corresponding to
ash.
Class B is used for uh flammable liquids
and gases.
Class C for electrical fire or
electronic fire. Class D for combust uh
combustible metals and class K or F for
cooking oils and pads.
So stop fire safety training know all
exit and extinguisher location.
Understand when how to use extinguisher.
Know how to manually activate for delays
suppression system. Be trained to power
down equipment safety and maintain good
housekeeping. No storage or cardboard
should be the server rooms.
So that's all for this domain. This
domain was lengthy and uh I must I must
be honest. I just uh uh went through
this domain very quickly without much
explanation
but that will not be the case for the
upcoming domains specifically the domain
four which is my specialty the network
and the communication domain. So stay
tuned and we'll see you in the next
domain.